a giant fork-tongued lizard with
razor-sharp teeth
and a bite with bacteria-laced venom
that's seeping into your flesh
well this is no legend
it's a komodo dragon
what would happen if you were attacked
by one of these giant
lizards what would be your best bet to
fight it off
and if you escaped
how long before its venom would leave
you in a pool of blood
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you were attacked by a komodo
dragon
komodo dragons also known as komodo
monitors are the largest lizards in the
world
as adults they have an almost uniform
stone color and can weigh around 70
kilograms
the largest komodo dragon ever found
weighed
166 kilograms and was more than three
meters long
they're powerful voracious eaters with a
taste for all kinds of meat from small
rodents up to a large water buffalo
their wide jaws and strong throat
muscles allow them to devour huge chunks
rapidly
and they can eat up to 80 percent of
their own body weight in one meal
sadly they are an endangered species
with only 1
380 adult komodo dragons left in the
wild
they can be found in the lesser sunda
islands of indonesia
most fitting the island of komodo here
they live on beaches ridge tops and even
tropical savannah forests
just waiting for the perfect chance to
attack you
arriving on the island of komodo you'd
be excited and looking forward to some
peaceful vacation time but as you walk
around the tropical forests you'd be
blissfully unaware that komodo dragons
could already be stalking you
yeah their hunting strategy is all about
stealth and power
it comes down to their sense of smell
when they're on the prowl for food and
they can pick up the trail of rotting
flesh from up to four kilometers away
for the komodo it's not about taking a
whiff of air with their nose
instead their peculiar method involves
sticking out their long forked tongue to
sample the air
then they roll it back in touching it to
the roof of their mouth
here the tongue rubs against a sensory
organ that can detect different airborne
molecules
a komodo can then use these molecules as
a guide for what direction to head
toward
or it can stay perfectly still for hours
just waiting for the prey
in this case it's you
luckily you'd spot the yellow tongued
lizard before it attacks
now would be a good time to run but with
a komodo's running speed clocking in at
up to 20 kilometers an hour
you wouldn't get very far
the dragon would bite down hard on your
ankle the pain would be immense but
you'd fight back you'd punch its neck
trying to force it to let go of you but
no luck
maybe you'd better try prying open its
massive jaws with your own bare hands
you'd struggle and struggle but
it would work
although it would come at a cost
your hands would get sliced by the large
serrated teeth of the dragon
now you'd be bleeding profusely from the
leg and hands
time to get away and find help before
the giant lizard has you for lunch
but a worse fate may now lay before you
all over the komodo dragon's jagged
teeth there are bits of meat from its
last meal
those bits make the perfect breeding
ground for dangerous strains of bacteria
then that bacteria would now be
infecting your body
from your bite wounds you could be
exposed to 50 different varieties of
bacteria
some of these are highly septic
potentially leading to severe infection
but the worst still wouldn't be over
you would now have venom coursing
through your body too
this would lower your blood pressure and
prevent your blood from clotting
you could only have a few minutes left
before you bleed out
even if you slow the bleeding this would
be a terrible way to go
you could start to get the chills and a
fever your whole body would be in pain
eventually your heart and circulatory
system would begin to fail entirely
blood would no longer flow to any of
your organs causing them to fail
it's likely you wouldn't have the time
to make it somewhere safe and the komodo
dragon's hunt for you would resume
remember how they can smell rotting meat
from kilometers away
well your injuries would now attract
every komodo dragon around you
and while no komodo dragon could swallow
you whole on its own
a group of them would devour every scrap
of your body
yeah that's right they'd eat your bones
and your intestines
possibly even swinging them around a bit
to remove all the undigested contents
oh what a delicious meal
as scary and horrible as all this would
be you could rest a bit easier knowing
that it's extreme rare
it happens sure but prior to a deadly
komodo dragon attack on a young child in
2007 there hadn't been a single fatal
incident on komodo island in 33 years
maybe you should be more scared of
another giant predator attacking you
like a crocodile
but
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]